When it comes to planets, there’s a lot
more than meets the eye. Thankfully false
colour images show us what our eyes are missing.
Hey guys!
Amy with you on DNews talking pretty things
in space.
Thanks to decades of science missions, we’ve
learned a lot about what the planets are made
of, and that has let us figure out what their
true colours are. Mars is red because the
rocks are rusty. Venus’ surface is actually
grey but we can only see the thick sulphuric
acid atmosphere that envelops the whole planet.
Uranus and Neptune are both primarily made
of methane, a gas that absorbs red light and
bounces back blue-green light. That’s why
both planets have a rich, blue tone to them.
So if these are the planets’ true colours,
why do we sometimes see them looking like
a psychedelic vision?
Because false colour is a thing that scientists
love.
Across the whole electromagnetic spectrum,
the human eye can only see a small section,
the so-called visible light spectrum from
violet to red that corresponds to a wavelength
range of 400 - 700 nanometers. The human eye
can’t see longer or shorter wavelengths
outside the visible range, infrared and radio
on the longer end of the spectrum and ultraviolet
on the shorter end. So scientists use tools
to see in these wavelengths.
In some cases, imaging a body in a different
wavelength reveals things we can’t see.
This composite image of Saturn’s moon Titan
was taken in infrared light by the Cassini
spacecraft’s visual and infrared mapping
spectrometer. In visible light, Titan only
shows is hazy atmosphere, but in the near-infrared
we can see through the clouds to the surface.
Radar is another way to look through what
we can’t in visible light. This image of
Venus was made using radar data from the Magellan
spacecraft. The radar penetrated through the
dense atmosphere to reveal Venus’ surface
topography, and this colour-coded map makes
the information easy to read.
Sometimes looking in different wavelengths
is a way to see more detail. On the left is
Jupiter in true colour. On the right is a
false colour image made from three separate
pictures taken through filters focussing on
specific spectral regions: two were taken
through filters looking for the absorption
of the gas methane and one taken in a red
continuum that wouldn’t show any absorption.
The result shows details in Jupiter's atmosphere
that are invisible to the naked eye.
Some false colour images are designed to highlight
differences in surface material, like this
one of Mercury. Grey in visible light owing
to the iron rocks that litter its surface,
Mercury looks vibrant when colour is used
to enhance the separation between chemical,
mineralogical, and physical variation within
the surface material.
Another striking image is this one of the
dwarf planet Pluto. Red in visible light because
of tholins, this false colour image was made
using a technique called principal component
analysis that highlights the subtle color
differences between regions on the planet’s
surface.
There’s a lot to learn about the planets
from all kinds of stunning images, but it’s
not the case that whoever sees something first
can claim it as their own. There is such a
thing as space law, and TestTube News talks
about it in this video right here.
And there’s a lot more to space than just
planets!
If you want to come explore other facets of
space with me, come check out my own channel,
Vintage Space!
We’ll have a link in the description if
you’re on mobile.
So do you guys like false colour images or
do you prefer your planets au naturale?
Let us know in the comments below and don’t
forget to subscribe for more DNews every day
of the week.
So do you guys like false colour images or
do you prefer your planets au naturale?
Let us know in the comments below and keep
coming back to Test Tube for more DNews every
single day of the week.
So do you guys like false colour images or
do you prefer your planets au naturale?
Let us know on the Discovery News Facebook
page or on Twitter @DNews. And you can find
me; I’m @astvintagespace. Thanks for watching!